take a vertical line such as this marker
here and you scan from left to right
across the graph and you look to see if
the line crosses the graph at more than
one point so two or more so if I do that
there is a vertical line there is a
vertical line there is a vertical line
there's a vertical line so I'm scanning
across using vertical lines does it ever
cross the graph more than once no it
looks like it's only crossing once here
once here once here once here so as I
scan across it's only crossing at most
once so that means that for every x
value there's just one y value on the
graph so the x values are like the
inputs the Y's are the outputs if you
put something into your computer and one
time it opens one program another time
it opens a different program that's
unpredictable that's not a function so
let's look at this one over here so take
that vertical line scan from left to
right across the graph does it cross the
graph at more than one point actually
you can see it does see here it only
crosses at one point that's okay but
over here it's crossing at more than one
point so that means that when X is let's
say positive 2y could be negative 2 or
positive 2 you can see that for each
input ok or for this input there's more
than one output that's not a function so
this fails a vertical line test this one
here same thing we draw a vertical lines
as we scan from left to right it never
crosses the graph at more than one point
see it's just one one one so just one at
most once so this one is a function and
then this one over here you can see
right away it's crossing at more than
one point here it doesn't even cross the
graph at all here is just crossing at
one point but if it ever at any point as
you scan from left to right across the
graph if it crosses at more than one
point it crosses the graph at more than
one point then that means that Y is not
a function of X meaning that for each X
input there is more than one Y output
it's like this X is going to more than
more than one Y value so that fails the
vertical line test and it tells you that
it's not a function it passes it only
crosses one once or less than it is a
function okay so this has been an
overview of the vertical line test
in the next video